wow I wish  and the Rick defends the night it's a  very English  about countdown  TV show  so The Rook now defends the Black  Knights how can keep the momentum going  before it's too late oh oh oh whoa  Something's Happened  um it did feel a bit wrong for Magnus to  play this move I actually thought Magnus  had something a bit stronger but what is  in there  Rook takes C7 is a threat in Queen d8  wow  and actually if we look at this if the  Knight moves suddenly there's either a  knight H5 or queen B7 shot and that's  just over so for example this and you  come in and you get to the black king  that's just like that no reaction on  Magnus but he obviously has blunder  is seeing it now I think he's starting  to realize  um it's not actually obvious I mean if  you show